I want to jump to the store from the
post millennial we can't finish with
Jennifer Lawrence the poor girl she
never gets any time to him he has a
story from the post millennial majority
of Americans say Biden's anti-maga
speech was designed to incite conflict
the poll found that 56.8 percent of
likely general election voters said that
Biden's speech represents a dangerous
escalation in rhetoric and is designed
to incite conflict amongst Americans The
Babylon bees had their best night ever
they're like 30 Biden kicked out of
Austrian art school yeah yeah Biden
issues non-aggression-packed with Poland
I genuinely spit out laughing when I saw
that headline pop up
um yeah it was a CR I had to watch that
speech because I did a bunch of radio
and TV on it later on that night and
that was just some crazy fighting comes
out and he's like I'm the president and
I hate half this country
and then the next day they're like why
are you talking about Trump supporters
that was like ah I was not talking about
Trump supporters then he comes out and
like the policies proposed by these
people are a threat dude it is that
people fall for this or they lie is it
is it is insane pandering to the base is
gutting the Democrats and that's it's
it's backfiring already 56.8 percent
they don't like it independent voters
they don't like it
you're not going to win with just
getting Democrats well and especially
when you ran as being the unifier and
you became the divider in Chief I mean
that's really what's taken place here
and so we have to understand the fact
that what they're looking at and when
you're seeing headlines like this where
they're thinking oh this is to incite
conflict well that's because they
thought that the whole January 6th
incident was actually good for them
politically and they're trying to you
know basically utilize that to try and
Advance them and you know stop the red
way from coming in but you know look we
have to identify for what it is I mean
this is literally him calling half of
the nation extremists you know what that
speech reminded me of you know like and
especially in 80s or early 90s movie
where there's some bad thing happening
and finally someone stands up in the
high school gym and they give this
speech and all the bad guys put their
head down and realize they're wrong and
then finally someone courageously starts
the slow crap clap and everyone's like
yes and Justice is served that speech to
me sounds like it was written by a 26
year old kid who was a poli-sci major
who really thinks that if I just lay it
out like this this all those Trump
supporters are going to sit there at
home and say you know what guys I think
they're right I think like it was
written by a child but they didn't
identify but but they never did actually
say what it was that we as America First
candidates actually American sorry are
actually about they they didn't identify
I mean the people they described was
their own followers well and the thing
that cracked me up is that after the
speech of of calling us all these names
was one of his last lines was how we
have to start seeing each other as
fellow Americans did you just not listen
to the things you read off the
teleprompter for the last 20 minutes
like it really was whoever his
speechwriters are and boy this white
house has struggled with speechwriters
none more than kamala's of course
um but but it really was a child it was
a very immature speech it sounded like
that speech that a kid wants to give to
their mom because Mom didn't let me that
it was just a childish immature Petty
petulance
was it written I didn't see him reading
off a prompter or any no there's no way
that he rambled on that long without no
absolutely did he have like multiple
monitors around the room a lot of times
they have these see-through monitors
that are at a distance you can't see
because of the camera angles and they're
looking at the back shots but he's
sitting here when he's going left to
right it's because there's usually two
prompters that are up there that are
clear that actually have everything out
there do you really think he can't Joe
Biden can keep a continuous thought for
more than 30 seconds where he says
vanilla or chocolate ice cream remember
I don't think it's remember the uh
Remember The Simpsons episode where
Homer is like you have my undivided
attention and then it zooms into his
brain and it's like a turtle Flying Like
Old MacDonald or whatever like banging
on his chat that's what I imagine if I'd
taken this poll here I would have said
that it seemed like the speech was
intended to divide an Insight maybe I
don't even say kind of like divide
because of the red background correct
blood red background you see the wide
shot there's also all this blue and
there's just this little segment but all
the the media apparatus that wanted to
recorded it had just pure red one can I
just say one read it
but can I just say one thing though
whether it's Republican or Democrat one
of the things that disgusts me as you
know prior military and you know comment
veteran
we have to stop utilizing our military
for backdrop props you know this is
something that just shows absolute
disrespect because the thing that you
have to understand is is that when you
serve in the military you serve a
commander-in-chief and we don't think of
this as it isn't a political thing for
us and the fact that each the left and
the right try and utilize the military
as a political backdrop really needs to
stop I think it's illegal to to a
campaign with military present is that
uh it's a violation of campaign rules
that military and also like even police
and fire in the in their uniform they're
not they're not but not the personal
capacity the president is allowed to the
president the Vice President are allowed
to campaign if the military can't do
politics yes but that's why they say
this was not a campaign speech this was
a presidential speech again deep concern
for fossil fuel use we had a fly to
Philadelphia no fossil fuels to light up
Independence Hall right why couldn't
you've given the speech from the oval
right I don't know why and this is
something I've asked before in other
shows ever since Reagan really and maybe
a little bit Clinton presidents don't
use the oval anymore right Ronald Reagan
addressed everyone from the oval on the
regular when he gave a speech and I
don't know why what's changed but
presidents don't speak is there a more
presidential background Joe Biden than
the Resolute desk I know Joe Biden had a
Sound Stage built they have that weird
that that weird room where they do
why do you need a fake problem well I
think that one that one was obvious
because it was the back window was a TV
screen
and so they could pre-record what they
needed to to send it out so they didn't
have to worry about Biden you know but
president Trump though president Trump
did I I would say 90 unless he was
actually on an official delegation or a
visit or anything like that I mean he
did it from the Rose Garden or he did it
from the White House yeah he liked the
East room very much and he liked the
Rose Garden but I just I'm always
fascinated that we don't do more things
he did obviously there's always like
diplomats Etc
um impressors this was for theatrics
that that's what this is for for the
white Administration it's about
political rhetoric theatrics and and
trying to you know assuage every other
American from looking at what's really
going on in America yeah and this was
obviously produced you know there are
there are Advanced teams that put these
together Josh if you're still watching
he paid for most of them right I mean I
know people who do this for maybe
Jennifer Lawrence did this on her
part-time well someone had to decide
this is the backdrop imagine if
Independence Hall was just lit up bright
white and just light and just light and
and he gave out and he said you know the
Constitution was written here and we are
one America and I know we have a lot of
division but we can come together and
stop the division and and I want to hear
from you he could have given a speech
that even his greatest detractors would
say I hate the guy but you know what I I
can't disagree with that speech who
orchestrated this to say like this is
the backdrop this is the rhetorical this
is the tone this is the clenched fist
but according to according to the left
though they said that Biden has been too
soft and too polite and too nice and
he's again to to quote something that
Tim talked about earlier which is that
this is pandering to the left this is
continuing to try and go ahead and buy
into this rhetoric that this is somehow
going to prevent a red wave and actually
if he would have gone with the idea that
you had that would have probably
actually swayed more npas to the left
than it would have actually pushed him
to the right so Independence two to one
that's that's if you are running his
campaign right now that he could have
came out that keeps you up at night the
way Jennifer Lawrence has Tucker Carlson
nightmares independent voters are your
knight I think if he had come out well
people disagree If he if he had come out
and he pardoned January 6 supporters
the left would be forced to agree with
him you you laugh but that's actually
not that that's actually a great idea
the idea of him doing it I love the idea
it should have happened if you wanted to
talk about being a unifier and again
stop trying to look at the political
imprisonment if these individuals like
Jeremy Brown who's in Pinellas County
Jail who still has no charges levied
against him former Special Forces former
Ranger who literally has no charges
levied against him and never entered the
capital but has been in prison this
entire time I mean these are the types
of people that we need to be fighting
for I could say this without hesitation
if Joe Biden came out and pardoned all
the people from January 6th and he
called for an end to the hearings and
said we have to move past it he would
guarantee his re-election on Twitter
pardon someone is it a general pardon
like I pardon you for every crime you've
ever committed no just for the one
specific but that is it so right there's
not just a sponge from the record you
know at any level of the Judiciary no
one can bring up charges no one can
that's it it is done they would lose is
far left and the hard left they would
the moderates they'd gain the moderates
would be like like the you know the more
establishment crony Democrat types would
be like aren't we so Noble and
compassionate magnanimous yeah and then
the far left would be like we just want
a revolution and you're hurting that by
doing this and CNN would run to the to
the Mitt Romney's of the world and get
them to admit what a great guy he is and
like see even Republicans admit that he
is a great and it would guarantee his
re-election if he really wanted it it
would have actually have gone towards
his claim of being the universe
economics energy rolling blackouts I
don't know about that that's that that
is true I think we're just talking about
what would have potentially have been a
lot better which anything a rerun of The
Simpsons would have been better than
this right here it's like the the like
the military the Marines come out they
play the song and then they wheel out a
TV and just put a TV up and it plays an
episode of The Simpsons and and that
would have probably had a better rating
than this this felt like do you approve
of the rerun of The Simpsons Biden
played actually yeah we all really
enjoyed it they were like anticipating
if all the economy is crumbling is in
the okay we're gonna need to blame
somebody in the future so let's plant
the seeds now they've done the Maga
stuff as the the seeds are planted now
if [ __ ] really hits the fan we got a
villain that we can pin it on
um it's very Nazi Germany what they do
with the Jews that's what it felt like
to me it is and and when you have
40-year high record inflation when you
have 40-year high uh 30-year High Energy
prices when you have you're threatening
to disarm Americans you are literally in
a recession regardless of how we
determine the new definition is we are
literally in a recession when you look
at all the economic indicators
of the Suffering The American families
and and blue collar and working-class
Americans are feeling
um there is no reason why this guy
should should be in office so what do
you do you find a scapegoat and if it's
if it was it was the Jews in Nazi
Germany and now it's the Maga you're
absolutely right because I can't run on
the fact that that that oil prices and
energy prices and food prices are at
record high and talking about the
upcoming uh depression they're going to
get much much worse because winter
hasn't even kicked in yet we haven't
even harvested the wheat yet thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there